and seen it you haven't seen it you
crushed it
you crushed it hell yeah regrets Pedro
Pascal may have earned huge praise for
his performance in the last of us but it
turns out the star of the hit show has
yet to see the final episode while
chatting with Steven young for varieties
actors on actors series Pedro explained
why he hasn't seen the season one finale
there you go
not much further now actually I saw it
all up until it's just this bizarre I
haven't done anything for that amount of
time before and so my attachment to the
experience is something and it's a
strange thing kind of later you know as
a guy who's pushing 50 like to feel this
very very kind of like innocent
semi-angry
um emotional attachment to an experience
that is over you know it continues I
understand but like it will never be
another sort of like meeting Bella for
the first time working Craig working
with Craig with the entire crew Pascal
went on to praise His young co-star
Bella Ramsey after all we've been
through
everything I've done
can't be for nothing you have to tell
she was cool I knew that she was casting
the part before I was and I don't know
how they knew how to put these sort of
uh two pieces in place but I'm not
surprised that it started with um with
Bella and I couldn't have asked for a
more anchoring generous thoughtful
teenager and I don't mean to say that in
a patronizing way but it's just the way
it is you know yeah yeah and Pedro told
the beef star about a recent road rage
incident that got a little messy after
he cut someone off in traffic
my little sister was next to me in the
passenger seat and I was like yeah yeah
yeah
ah you know that kind of thing and then
I hear her go oh my God and I look over
and there is a big glob of saliva like
just like somebody like a nice Pedro
also dropped in for a chat on the most
recent episode of the smart list podcast
the internet has collectively referred
to as our daddy and that you embrace it
I've seen you in interviews and stuff
like you kind of like that it's kind of
cool look you got the Scruff going on
you wear the glasses I just want people
to like me
I love this story it turns out that
there was one movie that his strict Dad
wouldn't allow him to watch as a kid
706.
you have exactly eight hours and 54
minutes to ponder the error of your ways
I wasn't allowed to see The Breakfast
Club because wow because it was just
because it was what sent a bad message
it was like yeah it was like kids
complaining about their parents yeah
it's like you know watching that